>>Ankur: Hi everyone!
Welcome to another APAC Developer Office Hours.
For those of you who haven't joined us before
this is basically a session where you can
ask us questions live on Android development
and we can do our best to answer them live
or what we actually recommend is you post
your questions ahead of time and we provide
a moderator link for that, a Google moderator
link.
The best way to tune into this is through
Developers.Google.com/live and you'll see
all of the other office hours starred events
or all Google developer live events including
the Android ones.
So thank you for joining in today.
I'm joined here this week by Anirudh Dewani
from Bangalore.
>>Anirudh: Hi there, it's actually Hyderabad
>>Ankur: Hyderabad, I'm sorry, Anirudh.
>>Anirudh: It's alright.
>>Ankur: It's hard to keep track of your travel
and I often make mistakes so I apologize.
>>Anirudh: Anyway, it's great to be joining
and welcome all of you.
>>Ankur: And I am of course Ankur Kotwal and
I'm joining you from Sydney, Australia.
Today I'm in a secret closet, well it's not
really a closet but it feels like one and,
uh, so yeah, hopefully you've been having
a good day and a good week so far.
So what we usually do is we go to the Google
moderator link, we bring that up and we, uh,
we start looking at the questions.
So, uh
[Clears throat]
>>Ankur: I'm just gonna go ahead and do that.
Today we're gonna try something different.
We're gonna try screen sharing on Google plus.
Now, this could, of course, blow up in our
faces but I suspect it should be okay.
So let me try that, let's go screen share
and we will bring up the questions.
And today we have 9 questions and you know
people have voted on them.
So it's not too late to submit questions for
today's session.
This is live so we will, before we wrap up
for the day we will go in and check those
questions again.
So, let's get started then.
The first question is, "Looking at the APIs
available is there a Hangout API for web?"
I'm sorry, "There is a Hangout API for web
and a Google Plus SDK for Android "coming
soon."
Is there any plans to expose G plus hangouts
in the Google Plus SDK and if so, roughly
when will this functionality be enabled?"
That's a good question.
Before I answer it I just wanna also bring
up the next question because it's related
and it's this one here that says, "Any word
on when the Android SDK for Google Plus will
be available for download?"
So we've, uh, we've mentioned this before
that we actually can't share any dates with
you externally.
When it's ready and available we will make
the SDK public and available for all of you.
So let me just bring up, Developers.Google.com/plus
/mobile.
This is basically where the Google Plus SDK
will be found.
It's not out yet.
It's coming soon from for Android as was mentioned
and as I said, we can't really speak to the
dates and the honest truth is we don't actually
know the dates so we would probably be lying
if we made something up and we could get in
trouble for that so we'd rather not.
Basically here you'll find that it's, that
this is where you'll find the SDK when it's
released and don't you worry we'll be very
vocal about it so you'll know that it's out.
But, while it's still baking you can go ahead
and have a look at this page and you'll see
that it actually describes what APIs are going
to be available at the time of release.
So, I guess I'll just go through them quickly.
There'll be a sign in on Google Plus so you
can use the identity management side of things.
You'll be able to allow users to share content
from within your apps.
Of course, the plus one button will be there
to allow users to engage on Google Plus through
your app.
We also have something called history API
and we have personalization and there's some
APIs there.
You'll notice that we haven't made any mention
of the Hangout API.
The honest truth is I don't know whether there'll
be a Hangout API, if I did I probably couldn't
tell you about it.
So, anyways, the Google Plus mobile SDK is
for Android, it is coming soon and you should
just stay tuned.
Okay, let us go back to the questions.
Switch back.
And here we are.
So that's the first two questions that we've
answered.
The next one, "Are there any plans to provide
real multi session on tablets and APIs?
How about some services for games to save
the preferences of the user and saves on Cloud
level so that they can continue either on
tablet or phone?"
That's a very good question.
Hi, Andrew!
>>Andrew: Hi.
>>Ankur: We'll finish answering this question
and it looks like the next one is from you
anyway.
So we'll get to you in a minute.
>>Andrew: That works.
>>Ankur: Uh, actually, we just answered one
from you regarding the Android SDK for Google
Plus.
>>Andrew: Yeah, I saw that.
>>Ankur: Yeah, good.
[Laughter]
>>Ankur: So, multi session APIs on tablets,
like I said, this is one of those, another
one of those, "Hey, what's happening in the
future?"
type things.
You know, it is, what you're suggesting sounds
like a really useful idea.
So, we don't have anything to share right
now about whether such an API exists or is
coming in the future.
It certainly not available now but part of
it is and that part is the saves on a Cloud
level.
Right now there's probably two ways you can
tackle this.
One of them is using the backup service on
Android.
So, basically, you can, your app can backup
some information to the Cloud and then when
you fire up the app on other devices you can
restore that data.
Keep in mind it's not really designed for
real time seeking but you might find that
it's sufficient for what you're trying to
do.
It really depends on your situation.
The other way you could do it is through things
like the Google Drive SDK and use the Google
Drive, uh, the user's Google Drive as a way
of storing your data and then pulling it down
and syncing it with Cloud.
There was a really good presentation at Google
IO 2012, this year, on using the Google Drive
SDK on an Android.
So, I would suggest you have a look at that
and see where it lands you.
Is there anything else you wanna add to that
Anirudh?
>>Anirudh: Yeah, thank you.
So we don't have any real time Cloud backing
up for the session but you can save your preferences
by using one of the options with just the
backup API but it's not real time.
And then you can use the drive which can be
real time.
>>Ankur: Thanks a lot, cool.
Alright, Andrew it seems like someone bumped
you so I'll just get to them then I'll get
to you.
Hopefully they don't bump you again.
>>Andrew: That's alright.
[Laughter]
>>Ankur: Alright, we have a question from
Arpit.
He says, "I'm really trying to understand
the Android layout trend work.
I get that you have to override methods like
onmeasure and onlayout but what's the class
that's managing the entire lifecycle?
i.e. what's the class that measures the top
level container?"
>>Anirudh: Uh, I can take that one.
>>Ankur: I'm sorry, go ahead Anirudh, all
yours.
>>Anirudh: So, just give me a second to pull
up the question.
Right, so, all your views of the container
would be a layout, like a reading layout or
relative layout which is a view group.
So that would take care of the responsibility
of calling the methods unmeasured layout and
all the popular view groups are managed by
the form window manager and that would manage
the lifecycle of the view groups and the views
inside them and their layout and measuring
part.
>>Ankur: Cool, thanks.
I'd also just like to bring up a couple of
pages that might be useful for this person.
Again, if you go to, you can see the URL at
the top, Developer.Android.com/guide/topics/ui/overview.html
and it really gives you an overview of what
the view hierarchy is, how it's laid out,
what the relationships in that view hierarchy
are.
In terms of executing the lifecycle you'll
see overrides exist in the activity and also
in the view.
So in the activity, for example, you tend
to call set content view which basically goes
and sets the top level view in your hierarchy.
There is actually a root node that you can
get from the window called the [inaudible].
But this is getting in to fairly low level
stuff so it'd be interesting to just find
out from what perspective you're really asking
this question.
So check out the activity documentation and,
finally, also check out the view itself, the
view classes documentation because, again,
we go through in detail to say what all of
these overrides are and at what point they
are kind of cold.
And I know you alluded to sort of the fact
that you understood these ones from the view
but you might, these pages might just help
give you the broader picture.
Alright, I'm going to go back to questions
and we are at Andrew's question which is,
"On Android 2.3 and 3.x I can use the audio
texts successfully inside a web view, however,
when using the same app on Android 4.x I can
only play the audio file once.
The current time gets stuck at infinity after
the first play and can't be set back to zero."
Uh, Andrew, are you there?
>>Andrew: Yeah I'm here, yeah.
>>Ankur: So, I think I understood this question
but I haven't actually heard of this problem
before so what I was hoping for was if you
can just one, give us an overview since you're
here, you know, what the nuances around this
are, but if you can just provide a small example
that I can reproduce this in it would really
help.
>>Andrew: Cool.
Yep, I can send you a couple lines of htmls
at some point and demonstrate them.
It's really quite bizarre, I mean, I've got
this web app wrapping inside an Android app
and it's gonna be inside an iPhone app as
well.
But, yeah, it's just playing back the audio
files when you click on the little hyperlink
that I've got on my page, it'll play the audio
fine multiple times on Android 2.3 devices
and 3.
Whatever devices but as soon as I go to a
device that's got 4.0 or 4.1 you hit the play
button and it plays fine the first time but
then you can't play the sound file again.
It's stuck at, like I said, one of the attributes
is the current time and at the end of the
first playing through it's set to infinity
rather than kind of 3 seconds or whatever
the length of the sound file is.
And doing searches on the web would indicate
that you can just set time current time back
to zero to set the play head back to the start
of the sound file but that doesn't seem to
work so I was just wondering if there was
a weird freaky thing.
I mean, I've done lots of searches on the
web and lots of people have different ideas
about various bits and pieces but none of
the tricks seem to have worked so I just thought
I'd post.
>>Ankur: Okay, so, a couple of things just
on that.
It'll be great if you can also give us the,
um, some of those references where people
are discussing this
>>Andrew: Yeah, yeah.
On stack overflow I can send you some links.
>>Ankur: Yeah, that would be ideal and the
other thing I was going to ask you is if you
fire this up in the web browser
>>Andrew: Yep
>>Ankur: the built in browser on ice cream
sandwich and then also on Chrome, do you see
the same behavior on both of them?
>>Andrew: Yes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah it's the same on both.
So even though it's not even, like you say,
if you take away this web view inside the
Android app part and just run it in the default
browser you still get the same behavior.
If you run it inside of Chrome or Safari on
the desktop it works fine.
>>Ankur: That's quite interesting.
>>Andrew: Yeah.
>>Ankur: I must admit I haven't heard of this
problem before.
I only had the chance to do a cursory search
and I didn't find anything but maybe I wasn't
looking for the right thing.
>>Andrew: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'll try and put together little sample stuff
so I can send it through.
>>Ankur: Alright, great.
That would be appreciated and then maybe we
can talk about it next week.
>>Andrew: Yeah, yeah, sure.
>>Ankur: Alright, cool.
Uh, let me see, we asked the Android layout
question, we answered that one.
Alright, we have someone called "Gears" asking,
"How can I make an Android app efficiently?"
This is an interesting question and there's
several ways that you could, interpret it.
For starters let me just say that's also a
very broad question in that there's no one
simple answer.
In terms of being efficient about making it,
it's good for you to go through the docs.
So one way to interpret it is how do I, how
can I be efficient in the way that I develop
this app?
So make sure you're well aware of some of
the APIs that you're using, we have a ton
of best practices around, you know, developing
for Android so make sure you're familiar with
those.
Familiarity with eclipse is also a useful
thing.
In a multi developer environment you want
to use a robust version control system but,
you know, there's no one magic answer.
In terms of how to make your app itself efficient
which is the other way you could interpret
it, well again there's a ton of best practices
around there but some of those sort of the
basic ones don't do a lot of work in the main
thread cause that's also the UI thread.
So if you're doing a lot of processing or
you're doing anything across the network make
sure that you are doing that in a background
like you can use in an AC task or you can
use threads, there's a number of options there.
So make sure you utilize those.
Don't reinvent the wheel.
You know, if there's some good libraries out
there then utilize those, often they're quite
heavily optimized as well.
You know, again, this is a very broad question.
When it comes to layouts in UI we've seen
developers sort of make the mistake of nesting
tons and tons of layouts, you know, so linear
layout within linear layout within linear
layout, that's just really inefficient and
it's quite expensive too.
So, uh, those are the things that will tend
to slow down your app.
Anirudh is there anything you wanna add to
that one?
>>Anirudh: Yeah, just a quick thing.
So if once you're working with a lot of data
and, for example, if you have a news reader
app and you're fetching articles, do use the
synchronizing service because we have designed
it very efficiently and it patches the request
from different apps together so the device
is not waking up very often.
So, yeah, do use some these framework components
that you have instead of pulling your, doing
your requests in the timers or backgrounds.
Regarding tools, as Ankur mentioned, we have
an awesome new tool, the [unintelligible]
tool with Jelly Bean and it's really good
if you wanna analyze a performance in the
memory of your application.
So do, again, look at those tools before you
release your app and optimize it there.
>>Ankur: Yeah, thank you.
Alright, we have a question from Fung Lam
in Hong Kong, "In the IO12 app there is an
action bar/spinner, depends on whether you're
in vertical or horizontal mode on the action
bar and the view pager.
However, the tab index will update when you
swipe on the view pager, the spinner is not
updated.
When will it get fixed?"
So, uh, it seems to me like Fung, here, is
basically reporting a bug on the IO12 app.
Thanks for reporting it, Fung.
I will, it would probably best if you actually
report it to the project page itself because
the engineers that sort of built that app
are actually not in this hangout and you obviously
know the right test steps on how to reproduce
the bug.
So I would suggest you go there.
You may even contribute a patch if you want
to; it is an open source project.
So, yeah, I would say engage in an open source
manner.
Okay, next question, "For a person that has
not written a single Java application is it
beneficial to use the NDK, using Native C
as I believe, to write an app?
Can it be effective as one using the SDK and
writing Java code?"
Um, interesting question, so, it's, again
depending on your skills.
Using the NDK, it requires a bit more set
up.
The developer experience is, well the learning
curve for developers is a bit steeper so knowing
the language is one thing but you still need
to understand how the tools integrate, how
you set, build system, how you debug those
apps, you know, how you interoperate between
the native app and the sort of, the framework
of Android.
And, in general I think it's actually harder
to learn all of that rather than sort of learn
Java.
Again, that's a generalization, it depends,
you may be a really awesome C coder and you're
familiar with all of these sorts of things
and so you might find that more useful.
Probably the answer is give it a go and see
how it turns out.
I think it'll probably be easier, though,
to start in the Java side of things.
The tooling is a lot better and there's just
few points of failure.
Um, yeah.
>>Andrew: With the NDK stuff
>>Ankur: Yep.
>>Andrew: is it a lower level kind of API
than the one that's exposed to Java or is
it just a C interface to the existing things
like location manager and all that kind of
stuff?
Or is it more low level than that?
>>Ankur: It's, it's a big of both, actually.
So, so we expose some of the capabilities
of the framework to the, to the NDK stuff
too for your C and C Plus code but not everything
is there.
So some of it you end up having to build JNI
wrappers and going back and forth yourself
and not only is that a little bit more work
but then you now have to start considering
the performance cost of going, you know, marshalling
through that space all the time.
So, uh, yeah it's a bit of both.
Okay, well, next question I see we've had
a few more people join us so before I go ahead
with the next question [inaudible name] or
[inaudible name] do you guys have any questions
to ask?
>>Male #1: Yep, um, my question was related
to view flipper which was introduced as an
extension.
I was really just wanting to ask, actually,
what I'm trying to do is I have a [unintelligible]
related to my view flipper, view pager, sorry.
>>Ankur: View pager, okay, yep.
>>Male #1: And I'm trying to get the last
created fragment on an article of the page,
let's say on page 2, I have a fragment with
just the [inaudible].
What would be the most optimal solution for
that?
Because I'm not able to get it and when I
say get on my adaptor I get a new fragment
and when I'm trying to get it in the section
then it's not available at all.
>>Ankur: That's interesting.
So you would typically, I would suggest, oops!
The lights have gone out.
That's not so good.
Hey Anirudh do you just wanna take over for
a second?
[Laughter]
>>Anirudh: Yeah.
So I'm guessing in your adaptor you have coded
to say that get [unintelligible] done based
on the implex of the pager or a new instance?
>>Male #1: Yes.
>>Anirudh: You could possibly manage it as
just new instances and then [unintelligible].
I mean, I guess that's a part of your adaptor
implementation.
>>Male #1: Yeah.
>>Anirudh: So instead of saying
>>Male #1: What's the solution at this point
in time that I'm maintaining a kind of array
[unintelligible] which is keeping track of
fragments that have been created and then
if the fragment is already created after turning
the value as get particle of fragment?
>>Anirudh: That seems to be a fitting implementation
to me.
Are you incurring any type of performance
hit there or?
>>Male #1: Well, my, my point is in case when
I'm trying to access this particle of fragment
directly from view flipper by saying something
like, let's see here,
[Pause]
>>Male #1: Alright, if I try to say viewflipper.getcurrentitem
it's just index and if I say get item at [unintelligible]
>>Ankur: So what I would actually suggest
is rather than getting it from view pager
I would actually try to get it from the fragment
manager.
So when you extentiate it you can specify
a tag and then I would try and do find fragment,
what is it, find fragment
>>Male #1: That's not possible with expired
tag for this because at the time of extentiation
this fragment, I guess at the time, when you
say get item the adaptor itself gives a fragment
ID to it.
>>Ankur: I see.
So, the main use of, is your fragment a UI
fragment or is it just a class that you're
sort of reusing?
>>Male #1: UI fragment.
>>Ankur: So these UI fragments are going to
get recycled so I would suggest--sorry?
>>Male #1: Yeah.
>>Ankur: So I would actually suggest if you're
trying to get something very specific then
your solution kind of, it will work, it seems
like not the right thing to do because the
whole idea of the view pager is that it will
try and hold onto the page, the contents of
the pages only while it needs them.
So, typically what I've noticed is that if
your current page and one on either side it
tends to keep, so if you've got things that
are more than two of your current page it'll
actually try to recycle and reuse those fragments.
And that's probably why your get methods are
calling, I'm sorry, returning a new fragment
because the existing one has been recycled.
>>Male #1: But, uh, how can I use the same
instances if I always get a new one?
So, if I want to modify something on that
part of the fragment?
>>Ankur: So, this is kind of the difference
between sort of separating out your UI and
your data layer.
If you're presenting something, I mean, typically
what you're doing with those adaptors is your
marking the data as dirty and then you're
just asking the fragment to repopulate and
redraw itself.
So, rather than directly sort of modifying
some state on your fragment what I'd be doing
is changing the data in the background and
letting it flow through the adaptor so when
it's presenting that particular framework
it's gonna get the fresh data.
>>Male #1: But, for example, what the issue
will be with this thing is that I have something
on my foreground as a UI, it won't get refreshed
until my adaptor screen of that particular
fragment is created again.
That will again lead me to a different kind
of problem.
>>Ankur: Are you calling notified data since
it changed?
>>Male #1: I'm calling it but it does not
refresh it.
>>Ankur: Interesting.
[Background chatter]
>>Ankur: Are you using custom views by any
chance within the fragment?
>>Male #1: No.
It's all the normal views.
[Laughter]
>>Ankur: Yeah cause what should be happening
if you called notified data had changed it
should come through and basically, you know,
redraw the views.
>>Male #1: I placed even some logs in order
to see if I could get the get view quality
for the adaptor but even that would not help,
get item called again, but even that was not
happening.
So I was like, okay, what to do?
>>Ankur: Yeah, it almost seems like what you're
wanting is a static set of fragments and you're
using the view pager for that and the view
pager is something that typically tends to
recycle fragments and discard them when they're
not being used.
So it's almost like that's not a good fit
and I would, I would try and have a layer
of abstraction that's says, "Hey, this is
a statically defined allocated set of fragments."
And then try and link them up.
So, in a sense what you're doing with your
array list isn't so bad I just hope that the
glue between the view pager and that list
is correctly managed.
>>Male #1: I just wanted to ask, maybe it's
a stupid question but what exactly is the
difference between fragment state pager adaptor
and fragment page adaptor?
>>Ankur: Fragment, I'm sorry, what was the
first one?
>>Male #1: Fragment state pager adaptor and
fragment pager adaptor.
>>Ankur: That's an interesting one.
Um, I've not used the state pager adaptor
have you, Anirudh?
>>Anirudh: No, same, I haven't used it but
I know it's one of the options available in
the view pager library to view all the fragments.
>>Male #1: helping me in some sense I got
it from a blog that I just ordered because
the previous one was always ending me with
some different kind of values then what exactly
I wanted it's giving me that but why it is
giving me it I have no idea.
I was just curious about it knowing what exactly
is the difference between these two?
>>Ankur: Yeah, sorry, neither of us know off
the top of our heads.
We'd need to look into it and get back to
you.
[Laughs]
>>Male #1: Maybe you can help me with one
more thing.
I was just having a question, I hope I'm not
taking too much of yours.
>>Ankur: That's okay.
>>Male #1: What is different between view
animator, view flipper and view switcher?
Because apparently all three of them have
been working like something similar to each
other.
So, is there, what would be the difference?
>>Ankur: So, view flipper, so view animator
does a lot more than just flipping views.
View flipper is literally, you know, I've
got a list of views and I just wanna say go
from one to the next to the next in terms
of what I show.
View animator you can do a whole bunch of
like different types of animation things there.
View switcher, I don't know off the top of
my head.
>>Male #1: But, I, for the animation thing
I'm seeing I can't animate in and out of the
view pager and view switcher or adaptor, so
view flipper and view animator both of them
I can do in and out animations and they will
be doing almost the same job so I was like
is there any specific difference as an API
level or something like that?
>>Ankur: When you say view animator are you
referring to the view property animator that
we introduced in Honeycomb?
>>Male #1: View animator is a transition,
transition API that you have.
One of the transitions API.
>>Ankur: Um, yeah, sorry.
I'll need to look this up and get back to
you unless Anirudh knows what I'd suggest
is after this hangout is complete I'm gonna
send out the event for next week's one, if
you can just put the question in the moderator
then it gives us a chance to look ahead of
time and I'll have something ready for you.
>>Male #1: Gotcha.
>>Anirudh: One of the things is that View
Switcher can have just two views, two views
and I think flipper can have more than two
so that's one difference between view switcher
and flipper.
>>Male #1: Is that so?
>>Anirudh: Yeah, I think view switcher can
have just two views which I think you can
switch between and flipper can have more than
two.
[Unintelligible]
>>Male #1: Okay.
Alright.
So, view animator, view flipper via a little--
[Dog barks]
>>Andrew: Shh!
>Male #1:--but view flipper can have only
two views that's what you are saying, right?
>>Anirudh: View flipper has two views and
you can switch between those two.
>>Male #1: Got it.
Thank you.
>>Ankur: Andrew, either you're hungry or you
have a dog.
>>Andrew: Yes, I have a dog, sorry.
[Laughter]
>>Ankur: That's alright.
Um, okay, uh, next question.
We have, I think Fung Lam has added a few
and they've sort of been out voted so I'll
just go back up a little bit, "It takes longer
and longer time after we load an APK for the
update and before it is available for download,
why is it?"
Um, there's too many apps queuing the new
approach for APK update.
The answer is I don't know.
I didn't, we didn't realize that this was
an issue.
Fung, if you are online it'd be great for
you to just let us know what kind of times
are you seeing?
Are we talking from like 2 minutes to 4 minutes
or are talking from 2 minutes to like 4 hours?
>>Andrew: I've seen something similar as well
over the past couple of months.
It used to take about 15 minutes from hitting
the publish button on the developer console
before you would see your app appear in the
placed on device and maybe another half hour
after that before it appeared on the web.
Whereas now it's taking about an hour from
hitting the publish button to appearing on
the placed on device and maybe an hour and
a half or so before it appears on the web.
So, yeah, it does seem to be longer these
days then maybe 6 months ago.
>>Ankur: Okay, let me raise that with the
team.
I don't know if anyone has raised it before.
I wasn't aware of that so--
>>Andrew: It isn't really a problem it's just,
you know, maybe it's just due to the number
of apps or something that are out there these
days or the number that are being submitted.
>>Ankur: Yeah I don't want to speculate.
It could be that, it could be that we have
the security mechanism bouncer that could
be more thorough now which takes longer.
I honestly don't know and I'll need to find
out but thanks for raising that with us.
Going back to the questions we, we have one
from Soham Mondal from Bangalore.
"Typically my service stops working after
awhile after my app goes into the background
and I need to acquire a wake lock or use start
foreground.
What is the difference between using start
foreground on a service or acquire a wake
lock on a service?
Anirudh do you wanna start with this one?
>>Anirudh: Honestly, I don't know the answer
to this.
[Laughter]
>>Ankur: That's alright.
So I think, let's see, it'll be interesting
to see why it is your service is being stopped.
If you start your service in a certain way
it kind of says hey it's bound to this activity
or bound to this, to this particular foreground
process and so when that foreground process
goes away your service will also stop.
So it depends how you are binding to the service
and how you're starting it.
Acquiring a wake lock on a service, all that,
my understanding of that, all that will do
is stop the device from going into standby.
I don't think that there's a direct correlation
between having a wake lock and having your
service stay running unless you're acquiring
the wake lock in your activity in which case
it's not getting a chance to background.
So it really depends how you're binding to
the service and if you are, if you're allowing
it to sort of hang around after the, your
main activity's gone away or not.
So, I would look into that.
One way to look into this is just by putting
in a bunch of logging statements in there.
See if there's a correlation between when
your activity is paused or stopped or destroyed
and when the service is going away.
Okay, final question.
I'll just read this one out.
Oh no, we've already done this one.
It's the one about native development languages.
I don't see any more questions on there.
Does anyone on the hangout have any more questions?
>>Andrew: I just have one that's maybe not
related to Android specifically but you mentioned
earlier about the Google Plus SDK will be
coming out at some point in the future, for
Android.
There's already a kind of Google Plus API
which is hosted on Google Code I think.
Is that just gonna be replaced or is that
gonna be kind of in parallel or will there
be some crossover?
>>Ankur: Are you referring to the web API
that's there?
>>Andrew: Yeah, there seems to be a lot of
rest services that you can call to get things
like comments on various posts and stuff.
Is that gonna go away?
>>Ankur: So that web API will stay because
what we're bringing out is an Android API.
Right now you can consume, you know, basically
consume it like it's a rest service.
>>Andrew: Yeah.
>>Ankur: But what we're doing is building
an Android API which will give you all the
niceties of, you know, having like a method
call using the identity manager on the phone
or tablet.
So, yeah, there's nothing stopping you from
using that rest API.
It's probably gonna be a bigger overhead using
that than using the native SDK when it's available.
>>Andrew: Yeah, cool.
>>Ankur: Alright, now, before we wrap up today,
actually, we've got something a little bit
different.
We tried to do this last week and we failed
miserably.
We basically had an interview that we've done
with a developer called Animoca.
Now I'm unfortunately gonna have to try something
that's less than optimum to play this and
to do that I'm basically going to share the
YouTube video, do a screen share.
So what I'd request is that people that are
on the hangout, if you could please mute your
microphone because I'm having to use the speaker
in the mic, super low tech today, to play
this video.
Once this hangout is finished we will, it
will be available as a standard line YouTube
video as well for you guys to watch.
So I'll just start the video and let it run
it's thing.
[Pause]
>>Male #1 in video: Hi everyone.
I'm really excited to be here [inaudible].
This is our first interview in Hong Kong in
APAC.
Sitting on my lap is [Inaudible] our mascot
[inaudible].
To my right is [inaudible all names of team].
Guys, please introduce yourselves.
>>Male #2 in video: My name is [inaudible];
I'm the CEO of Animoca.
[Inaudible] publishes Android [inaudible].
>>Male #3 in video: I'm [inaudible]
>>Ankur: That's embarrassing, hit by buffering,
I had pre buffered this video or so I thought.
Let me just try it once more.
>>Male #3 in video: [Inaudible]
>>Male #1 in video: I see that a lot of your
guys' apps are free so what is your business
quality?
>>Male #2 in video: So, our apps are [inaudible]
so they're free to download and users do not
get paid and the organization is [inaudible].
We may have some advertising of [inaudible].
We have a few [inaudible] items also where
you go [inaudible] an experiment with all
possibilities.
>>Male #1: [Inaudible]
[Cannot understand]
>>Male #4 in video: The characters will actually
move by themselves.
This is actually a great aide for the teams
cause they don't have to manually drag things
everywhere and you can adjust the speed and
skip levels and stuff like that.
However, this is not a replacement for action
[inaudible].
>>Ankur: Alright, So that was, firstly we'd
like just to thank Animoca for helping us
there and being part of that.
We hope that that was some useful advice.
You can see that Animoca's a developer that
headers for a wide variety of Android devices
many of which you wouldn't of even heard of
that we got to see some of them.
They were kind of sharing their tips for success.
So
if there's anyone on here on the hangout right
now that has questions around the interview
or anything else that we haven't addressed
today, now is your chance.
If you are watching this as a recorded segment
you can feel free to send us some questions
via the Google moderator link for next week's
show as well.
So we have Andrew and Thompson on the line,
do you guys have any follow up questions?
No?
Alright, I think before we go though, Anirudh
wanted to make an announcement.
>>Anirudh: Yeah, hi, this is for [inaudible]
we are hosting a code labs on the 3rd of August
and this is on SDK and tools in SDK for performance
analysis and reanalysis so the registrations
are open for the event and we have a link
shared, Ankur if you could bring that up on
the screen.
[Laughter]
>>Ankur: I actually can't.
If you can just pop it in the chat for
this hangout then I can bring it up right
now.
>>Anirudh: Alright.
I can do that.
>>Ankur: Yeah.
Thanks.
>>Anirudh: So, anyway, we will drop the link
in the post on G Plus and you can register
and join us for the code lapse then.
>>Ankur: Alright, so Anirudh can you just
let us know, you said in India but I'm sorry,
was it one event?
Multiple events?
How many cities?
>>Anirudh: This is one event in New Dehli
in the office in Gurgaon, the Google office;
we'll be hosting it there.
This is one event for now and we are looking
at other events in other cities but we don't
have any plans right now.
>>Ankur: Okay, fantastic.
And we will make that, the, uh, the link,
we will post it on Android developers, the
Google Plus page.
We'll also post a link to that video and allow
you guys to submit any questions so we can
address them.
Anyways, thanks for watching, thanks for joining
those of you that were able to join us on
the hangout and we will see you next week.
>>Andrew: Cheers, guys!
>>Anirudh: Bye!